nah it's brutal dude like yesterday
it was been like the first day of school
you know like have my outfit picked out
and everything
had to stay at home that sucks missed
out playing with all my friends
uh but yeah you know did not contract
the virus uh took one luck at me ran the
other way
it's probably in its best interest so um
here we are we're back on tuesday ready
to roll just had a good place in
football
only gardner mitchu could come up with
something like that and it's great with
it the virus took a look at it and ran
away i'd love to know what his outfit
was selected for the first day of school
probably that same shirt probably jorts
cut off above the pockets with the
pockets hanging under the frayed
material but that's gardner minshew and
getting ready for his first season as
the wire to wire starting quarterback he
got thrust into the fray week one last
year against the chiefs when nick foles
broke a collar bone fairly early in that
week one loss to kansas city and this
was supposed to be the opportunity for
minshew you know all through the
off-season to get properly ensconced he
has to do it on a more compressed basis
now that they're they're finally getting
close to the practice field what do we
think what do we think just what's your
what's your expectation for minshu this
year like potential you know he's one of
the guys i'm very excited to see play
this year in the nfl i mean he certainly
opened my eyes a number of times last
year first off just you see in what we
just saw right there
he has a charisma and a way about him
where you could see why fans gravitate
towards him players gravitate towards
and why the organization goes hey we
want to give this guy a chance he's got
some moxie he does he's got guts he's
got some playmaking ability too you know
he is one of those guys that we talked
about so much during my quarterback
rankings that he can make a play when
the offense does not deliver somebody
open or an easy completion or something
like that and that does excite me about
him now i can't necessarily sit here and
say i know the player yet i'd like to
see a little bit more of him but i do
think there is you know potential for
this guy to be something and solidify
himself as the starting quarterback in
jacksonville but i'm just not totally
sold on it yet i saw some that makes me
excited i'm just you know i need to see
a little more evidence i guess is what i
would say
well based on what we know now let's do
a little speed round here would you
rather bank on the next three years of
gardner minshew or the next three years
of and we're going to take them one at a
time but let's do it quickly minchu for
three years or jared goff for three i i
gotta still go with jared goff right
here i do again like i said i just don't
know about gardner minshew and yes jared
goff has flaws i know about goff yeah
yeah i know you know about golf but i
still think what we know about goff
right now i'm still going to say is
better than gardner minchu so from that
standpoint i'm going to take goff still
i'd roll the dice with minshew because i
hear you right now neither one neither
one's going to win me a super bowl i'll
take my chances with minshu mitchell
trubisky
or gardner minshew i'm taking gardner
minchu i am
you know this is just a guy that's more
natural at the position understands how
to play quarterback everything about it
there
uh i get it i'm i'm off the mitchell
trubisky bandwagon i saw enough last
year i tried to stick up for him for the
first few years yeah i'm going gardner
yeah sorry speed round gardner uh
trubisky took a team to the playoffs i i
want to see what he does in an offense
that fits his talents it's a closer one
for me actually but i'll go minshew sam
darnold i'm going sam darnold i'm not
giving up on sam darnold i mean i think
sam darnold has talent he's a franchise
quarterback need some help around him
what are you doing sam darnold sees
ghosts the ghosts would run away from
gardner minshew i'll take adventure
teddy bridgewater
oh wow
man this is a tough one here hmm
you know i uh
i'm gonna i'll take gardner minchu here
i'll take gardner minchu here i will you
know and again it's hard to say because
i just don't know if we've seen enough
about gardner minshew but i'm way more
excited about his top end than like what
you've said already we know what teddy
bridgewater is maybe he can change as a
player this year but uh teddy's a game
manager and a check down charlie and
that that always bothers me
i want a guy that i feel like is going
to take me to a super bowl and win it
and i don't know whether or not mint
sure is that guy most of these other
guys i kind of know that they aren't all
due respect they aren't that guy last
one speaking of that guy derek carr i'm
going derek carr i'm i'm i'm going in on
derek carr this year i think he's gonna
you just don't want to get blocked on
twitter uh yeah i don't give a damn
about twitter anyways but i i do i
listen i think derek carr is underrated
i think he's shown he can deal with
gruden and maybe he's got some talent
around him to shut all of us up this
year now we'll see
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports